but we begin with breaking news from
overnight after months of negotiations
senate democrats say they finally have
the votes to pass a massive spending
deal to try and tackle climate change
and inflation for more on what's in the
bill and what it means scott mcfarland
joins us live from capitol hill this
morning scott kirsten cinema came
through for the democrats last night
when are you thinking that there could
be a vote on this
good start this weekend david good
morning they are going to work and vote
through the weekend to finalize this
deal with no republicans on board
democrats need all 50 of their members
to vote yes and overnight with kyrsten
sinema of arizona announcing support
they appear to have their 50th cinema
was late to commit to this deal she had
concerns about tax provisions and her
colleagues appear to have relented now
preserving tax breaks for investment
fund managers so what is in this bill
democrats call the inflation reduction
act well there are new taxes to help
generate billions of dollars to pay down
some of the national debt but also to
pay to extend some of the subsidies to
provide health care under the affordable
care act democrats are also calling this
the largest climate change legislation
in u.s history it'll pay for tax breaks
for people who buy energy efficient
appliances or fuel efficient cars as
well as financial incentives for
businesses that conserve energy
if democrats can pass this bill it is a
big victory for the biden administration
and for congressional democrats with
less than 100 days till the midterm
elections they want something new to
show voters
as for the voting here it begins
tomorrow afternoon it could easily run
through early next week michelle
and the polls seem to suggest they need
some help scott thank you